>> Laura: SPEAKER PELOSI IS
OPENING UP A NEW FRONT.
HER WAR AGAINST THE TRUMP A
ADMINISTRATION A REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP IN CONGRESS.
HE OR SHE IS TAKING A SHOT AT MY
NEXT GUEST.
>> MITCH McCONNELL SEEMS TO
TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN CALLING
HIMSELF THE GRIM REAPER, IT IS
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         P
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         L
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         T
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         C
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         L
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         M
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         A
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         G
PART OF HIS COLLATERAL         ,
IT IS PART OF THE PRIDE HE TAKES
AS A LEADER OF THE SENATE.
AS YOU SEE, NONE OF THESE THINGS
ARE GOING TO PASS, THEY WON'T
EVEN BE VOTED ON.
SO THINK OF ME AS THE GRIM
REAPER.
>> Laura: THE GRIM REAPER?
WHAT?
SENATOR MITCH McCONNELL, YOUR
RESPONSE TO THESE NEW ATTACKS
FROM NANCY PELOSI COMPLETE WITH
PROPS AND POSTER BOARD.
MITCH McCONNELL'S GRAVEYARD.
>> SHE'S GOT IT RIGHT,
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MY MEMORY,
I AGREE WITH NANCY PELOSI.
I AM INDEED THE GRIM REAPER WHEN
IT COMES TO THE SOCIALIST AGENDA
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN GINNING UP
OVER THE HOUSE WITH OVERWHELMING
DEMOCRATIC SUPPORT AND SENDING
IT OVER TO AMERICA, THINGS THAT
WOULD TURN US INTO A COUNTRY WE
HAVE NEVER BEEN.
THEY ARE ON OUR WAY TO DOING
THINGS THEY HAVE ALREADY DONE,
THE GREEN GREEN NEW, MEDICARE
FOR ALL -- BY THE WAY, YOU MAY
HAVE MENTIONED THIS ON YOUR SHOW
BUT THEY PLANNED TO MAKE THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA STATE, TWO
NEW DEMOCRATIC SENATORS,
PUERTO RICO, TWO MORE DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS, AND AS A FORMER
SUPREME COURT CLERK YOURSELF,
YOU'VE SURELY NOTICED THAT THEY
PLAN TO EXPAND TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
THIS IS A FULL SOCIALIST MARCH
ON THE HOUSE AND THE OUTCOME AS
LONG AS I'M THE MAJORITY LEADER
OF THE SENATE, NONE OF THAT
STUFF IS GOING ANYWHERE.
>> Laura: IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT CAN GET DONE FOR THE GOOD
OF THE COUNTRY WITH THIS HOT
POLITICAL CLIMATE THAT WE ARE
IN?
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING WITH PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER,
SEVERAL HUNDRED JUST IN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS FROM AFRICAN COUNTRIES
NOW?
>> I CAN TELL YOU WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO ON THE HUMANITARIAN
PART OF THE PROBLEM DOWN TO THE
BORDER, SENATE DEMOCRATS
INSISTED ON STRIPPING THAT OUT.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THE
PRESIDENT HAS HAD MORE
COOPERATION FROM THE MEXICANS
THAT HE HAS FROM THE HOUSE AND
SENATE DEMOCRATS SO FAR IN
DEALING WITH THIS CRISIS.
>> Laura: THE OTHER THING WE
ARE HEARING A LOT, EVEN FROM
SOME OF YOUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES IS THIS CONCERNED
THAT YOU REFUSED TO MOVE
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD PROTECT
THE COUNTRY FROM FUTURE ELECTION
MEDDLING.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WRITING
TODAY, PARTISAN POLITICS IS A
REASON MITCH McCONNELL IS
STANDING IN THE WAY OF BETTER
ELECTION SECURITY.
FOR HIM, ALL THAT MATTERS IS A
WIN, AND IF HE COMPROMISES AND
CORRUPTS OUR DEMOCRACY.
SENATOR, THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING ABOUT YOU.
EVEN MARCO RUBIO WANTS SOME
LEGISLATION.
>> WHAT NONSENSE.
I THINK YOU OUGHT TO COMPARE THE
2018 ELECTION WHEN THE TRUMP
ELECTION WAS IN CHARGE TO THE
2,016TH ELECTION WHEN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS IN CHARGE.
ANY STORIES ABOUT THE LAST
ELECTION?
JUST A HANDFUL OF MINOR STORIES.
THIS ADMINISTRATION DID A
TERRIFIC JOB OF WORKING WITH
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS TO
MAKE SURE WE HAD AN HONEST
ELECTION IN 2018 WITH MINIMAL TO
NO INTERFERENCE.
WHERE IS THE APPLAUSE FOR THAT?
I'M OPEN TO CONSIDERING
LEGISLATION BUT IT HAS TO BE
DIRECTED IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
UNDERMINE STATE AND LOCAL
ELECTIONS.
THE DEMOCRAT WOULD LIKE TO
NATIONALIZE EVERYTHING.
THEY WANT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE OVER THE ELECTION
PROCESS BECAUSE THEY THINK THAT
WOULD SOMEHOW BENEFIT THEM.
ELECTION SECURITY, I DO CARE
ABOUT.
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
SUBJECTS OF ELECTION SECURITY --
>> Laura: SENATOR, THE BIG
NEWS YESTERDAY WAS WHEN GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS TITLED AROUND THE
OVAL OFFICE DESK AND PRESENTS
THIS SCENARIO TO THE PRESIDENT
WHERE FOREIGN GOVERNMENT COMES
AND PLOPS DOWN RESEARCH ABOUT
HIS OPPONENT IN THE PRESIDENT
SAID, WELL, MAYBE I WILL GO TO
THE FBI BUT I WOULD PROBABLY
LISTEN TO THE INFORMATION.
DO YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
ANSWER?
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE
TAKING THAT AND SAYING, WE TOLD
YOU SO.
NOW IT'S ON TO IMPEACHMENT.
>> THEY JUST CAN'T LET IT GO,
LAURA.
I SAID WEEKS AGO, CASE CLOSED.
WE GOT THE MUELLER REPORT, THE
ONLY OBJECTIVE EVALUATION THAT
WILL BE CONDUCTED.
NOBODY HAS ANY CONFIDENCE THAT
THE DEMOCRATIC HOUSE IS GOING TO
ENGAGE IN ANY KIND OF
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
THE CASE IS CLOSED, WHY DON'T WE
MOVE ON AND SOLVE THE BORDER
CRISIS AND PROVE TO THE MCA THAT
A TRADE DEAL WITH MEXICO AND
CANADA?
[LAUGHTER]
WE HAVE WORK TO DO.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT MADE A MISTAKE IN THE
WAY HE ANSWER THAT QUESTION WHEN
HE SAID MAYBE I WOULD, MAYBE I
WOULDN'T.
I WOULD HEAR THEM OUT.
WOULD YOU ANSWER THE QUESTION
THAT WAY?
>> HE GETS PICKED AT EVERY DAY
OVER EVERY DIFFERENT ASPECT OF
IT BUT THE FUNDAMENTAL POINT IS
THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO KEEP THE
2016 ELECTION ALIVE IN THE
INVESTIGATION ALIVE WHEN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE HEARD
ENOUGH.
THEY GOT THE MUELLER REPORT,
THEY WOULD LIKE FOR US TO DO
SOME BUSINESS.
I WOULD ASK THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE THIS: IS THERE ANYTHING
YOU'RE WILLING TO DO OTHER THAN
HARASS THE PRESIDENT FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS?
ANYTHING AT ALL?
>> Laura: FINALLY I WANT TO
TURN -- WITH ALL THE
CONFIRMATIONS, THE SUCCESSES
YOU'VE GOTTEN THROUGH.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALWAYS
BEEN PRETTY TRANSPARENT ABOUT
POTENTIAL NOMINEES, HOWEVER, I
THINK THE LEFT IS BASICALLY
GETTING READY, AS YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER, TRYING TO PACK THE
COURTS IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
THAT THEY WIN IN 2020.
IT'S ALL BEING FUNDED, WE FOUND
OUT YESTERDAY, BY DARK MONEY
GROUPS, WHOSE NAMES WE WON'T
KNOW, ARE NOT GOING TO BE
REVEALED, AND THIS COUNTS AS A
CLAIM, A FORMER OBAMA AND
CLINTON AIDE WARNS "THE NEXT
DECADE COULD FEATURE A RADICAL
RIGHT SUPREME COURT THAT COULD
ERADICATE GAINS AND PREVENT
POLITICAL ACTION."
SO WHICH IS IT?
WILL THE COURTS TO BE CHAMPIONS
FOR THE LEFT OR TOO DARN FAR
RIGHT?
SPEAK OF THE KIND OF PEOPLE
WE'VE BEEN NOMINATING BELIEVE IN
THE SIMPLE, QUAINT NOTION THAT
MAY BE THE JUDGES OUGHT TO
FOLLOW THE LAW.
I AM AMAZED THAT THAT IS
CONTROVERSIAL, BUT THEY ARE
BEING UPSET ABOUT IT REVEALS
THAT THEY WANT THE JUDICIARY TO
BE JUST LIKE OUR LEGISLATIVE
BODY.
AND HAVE OUTCOMES IN MIND BEFORE
THEY'VE HEARD THE ARGUMENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE NOMINEES, NOT
ONLY DID THE PRESIDENT MAKE TWO
GREAT NOMINEES AND NEIL GORSUCH
AND BRETT KAVANAUGH, BUT WE ARE
MAKING AN IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE
FOR THE COUNTRY THAT WILL LAST
FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND MY
MOTTO FOR THIS CONGRESS IS LEAVE
NO VACANCY BEHIND.